skin problems are always nutritional
deficiency diseases obviously there's
some certain infections but 99% of the
time things that don't respond to
medical approaches or nutritional
deficiencies and invariably their
secondary nutritional deficiencies
meaning the person has usually gluten
intolerance
they can't have wheat barley round oats
if they do eat wheat barley and rye
notes they get it contact enteritis and
this causes our intestines inflamed some
divers will call it leaky gut syndrome
celiac disease appendicitis
diverticulitis here low bowel syndrome
inflammatory bowel disease we're talking
about things like Crohn's disease all of
these are due to gluten intolerance well
at that point you cannot absorb
nutrients particularly the omega-3
essential fatty acids which results in
asthma as well as things like dermatitis
eczema psoriasis rosacea on the face and
your intestines look like your skin does
and you have to get off of gluten all 90
essential nutrients you have to take the
16 minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential
amino acids 3 essential fatty acids I
would take extra of the omega-3
essential fatty acids the EFA pluses
take three of those twice a day for 100
pounds of body weight and eczema nazma
dermatitis and asthma psoriasis and
asthma rosacea nazma usually go away and
anywhere from 3 to 4 months